so i listened to the second session and
i think three very important questions
were asked the first question if was
criticized that the world readers
treat the conflicts of the world as if a
word conflict would be like a
mathematical equation it would have be
a solution a good solution but these
conflicts cannot be solved mostly they
can't they must be handled they must be
kept under control but they are not
mathematical equations people are not
numbers second was a very important
issue is about veteran in a democracy we
need a cultural need basically people
believe that they don't because
everything's about quantity nothing
about quality but wrong i think those
participants raised the question is this
spirit the right democracy needs a
culturally and the third issue was about
education whether the education
institution should be like a marketing
institution that is produce
kits for the market and behave as a
market and that's wrong it's absolutely
wrong they have a right it is wrong it
has to do with the first second question
if democracy needs a cultural lead then
in cultural institutions especially
educational institutions should not
function as a market because not not
this is their function their function is
to create a cultural elite
how did our education becomes market
oriented and what is to be done it
happened in the last half a century that
education became market oriented in two
senses education institutions became
behaved as institution of the market
they became a market they were producing
young people for certain kind of
professions and people young people took
a kind of profession in order to get a
better salary but
better position that's all wrong because
and it's wrong even from the standpoint
of
technology even the standpoint of physic
chemistry because if you teach
young people the physics or chemistry
which is actually the leading branch in
science the moment they finish school it
won't be any more
important for this branch of science or
if you learn something with general
universal you learn philosophy higher
mathematics higher physics greek or
latin language so and logic and
philosophy learn all these capacities
abilities to argue to things up in
abstract notions to think logically so
to
constant concentrate and to contemplate
and to memorize you
you learn everything which you later on
can actually you can use it
it's not a specialized subject matter
but you can use it all possible
specialized subject matters
you're on the first panel so we've been
talking a lot about the crisis in our
world and the 20th century how do you
see the 21st century is it going to get
better or worse i cannot i don't see any
at the 21st century we are at the
beginning of the 21st century i think
things at the beginning of the 20th
century think about
1912
but in 1912 you could have foreseen
what's going to happen in 14 or 34 or
or 33 or 50 or 42 it was impossible so i
think at the present moment
right now 2012 100 years after 9012 so
we cannot know we cannot possibly know
what's going to happen in our century we
can only hope that it will better far
better than the 20th century but we have
to contribute to this betterment here is
the problem of changing the world
you cannot change the world as such but
if you have in mind that this
conflict between democracy and
totalitarianism
especially in europe between
republicanism and monopolism which is a
european conflict from the beginning of
modernity that in this situation in this
conflict you have to take the position
of republicanism of democracy essence
one of artisan totalitarian government
and that the danger of the territories
is not gone this danger is always
present in the modern world because it
is a modern political institution it was
totally wrong when people believe that
total is something middle-aged or
something reactionary it's it's
absolutely the case it is as modern as
democracy and that's why in a modern
world you have to face the danger that
they can be reborn and this basically we
change the world in order
to prevent
the world from embracing against
different kind of forms of monopolism or
totalitarian movements and states
all right and
what's that mean for the individual we
that live in this complicated
modern age how should we live to live
right
it's a very difficult question
how to conduct a good life
in a modern world
i have an answer to this question but i
think the answer is
which looks complicated is basically
simple we have to choose ourselves we
have to choose of us ourselves as decent
human beings and if we once have chosen
ourselves as decent human beings then we
will become
a kind of person for which you have
chosen ourselves that is if you choose
ourselves as this being we will become
decent beings now the other things which
we can do be a decent citizen a good
citizen who does not spare money either
money
time
a
participation effort
for helping
the republican institution
to
stay alive
and to develop
and the third question is how can you
influence the public
you are philosophers sociologists
journalists etc etc
and has to learn
to translate the
issues of our own
specialty
into a common language so that everyone
can understand it you cannot educate the
public in another way if you control the
public with the sophisticated language
of your subject matter
they don't understand it and they push
it aside so you need to learn how to
express yourself in the language
everyone who gives the minimum effort
everyone can understand this is why you
can contribute to the development of a
of culture discursive culture is very
very important that is the public what
does the public learn to argue to listen
to argument of the others
not to abuse someone because he has a
different opinion to sync with his or
her own mind to learn to sing with the
mind of someone else
and then to try to think in a way
consistently and this is what people can
learn that people can learn of course we
have emotions we have passions we are
one sided everyone has his or her
prejudices there is no person without
prejudice we don't look at ourselves as
others look at us and vice versa and
this is true about cultures you are a
dutch you don't look at the dutch uh in
the way as germans or english look at
the dutch and vice versa you have all
prejudices obviously the how can you
overcome this religion not entirely but
only by listening to the other opinion
not rejecting the other that's what he
says is rubbish and that's an alien
that's an enemy but the other has also
his or her opposition have to take the
other seriously you will not overcome
your prejudices thereby but you still
enter kind of discursive culture